Fame glamour perfection et si vous
pouviez tout trouver au bout d'une aiguille
ici à la Lucas Clinic, nous nous efforçons de
vous rapprocher plus que jamais de la célébrité
avec des échantillons tirés directement de la
source, vous pouvez être connecté d'une manière que vous n'auriez
jamais imaginée  pas d'accord que la
manie entourant la célébrité atteint
un niveau malsain non je ne veux pas que mes
clients se sentent plus connectés à ces
gens qu'ils voient dans les magazines
et à la télévision apprécient jusqu'à présent j'ai eu
toutes ses maladies ouais ça devait être
cher pour eux de toute façon répandez-le Je
ne vais pas bonjour les gars c'est assez
choquant a
commencé à jouer en saignant
combien de bouches ont compris je ne
semble pas m'asseoir à l'embolie
vous vous impliquez dans quelque chose depuis que
nous sommes une entreprise